leaving cold air and a Wallens for
there's the first looking for holes era
the man the myth the mother beast I
don't care if your name is nicko simple
or call in for the score eSports you do
not want to go toe-to-toe with this guy
in a server he has impeccable game sense
incredible aim and yes an ice-cold
demeanor in and outside of the game try
to stop dude don't worry this week on
best of we're looking at the absolute
finest from the coolest man in
counter-strike coldzera
now where do you start when you're
talking about a man who is arguably the
best in the world at what he does well
why don't we take a look at his early
days in luminosity luminosity their
roster for fallen steel bolts and the
new man cold Zehra he's gonna be kind of
being that new factor for them intrigued
to see how much he could do I think the
most playing world is
[Music]
old Sara Sara I think he is the most
consistent player in the world I think
he is the rock of the team he played for
the quarter maybe game angle he's got a
really sick angle here I just popped out
straight away there's two players on the
ball slide itself so with the boost hear
nor see they're actually looking
fantastic they're gonna send the top
bracket cold straight and he's gonna
take down freakazoid so they don't even
know what's hitting them at this point
swishes to the cset completely
annihilate it's nothing and the DPS can
come in here now spending at Oh a player
has pushed let the leash I think into CC
he's gonna come over to kill fallen nfx
and they're finally on the later another
fight two of his own to think three of
the ridiculous third shot often Tico who
is up on the catwalk
[Music]
and here we go again in the door
[Music]
many jump busy and in one hand the mp7
ones alone or worn the bomb type and
finishes the pyro from the bit as well
it's absolutely amazing from goes out
utility to work with no not again I've
got to end this thing before it begins
luminosity again going for the four-man
stack here at the a bomb site
interrogate gonna open it up are they
gonna check the corner just call this
whole DS phrase 1 2 & 3 / 4 that is
chemical called racking TSM you guys
already know this but in csgo some
people are offers some are rifle errs
and some can just do it all put any
weapon into colds era's hands and this
man makes incredible things happen with
or without the rest of his team all the
way over toward atrium caps it goes
quite cold zeros quicker gets a second
as well as the bomb will go down and
follows it up they're all lining up cool
there with the name but beautiful one as
well and he's elated for good reason oh
it's fallen left and got the first Thema
is out kickert not found yet tries to go
oh no kickert with a kill on Felton now
cold in the corner so much trouble
that's trying to see the hunted
and the next one from taco dropping
Dupree through the wall does make
contact but it's not a kill now they
know exactly where the AWP is but they
still don't deal with it well because
they walk in give cold the angle and he
goes and finds another one to get Cajun
B and a c1 from Maine and one from pop
dog cold with just the 8 HP looks to be
enough to shut them all down the back
if they succeed on babe this gets a
little scary yeah this is gonna be a
pinch towards the bebop side bursters
there to cut off rotations maybe do it
late lurk and actually he's found a
pretty good timing
oh wow making em off for brains misfits
being able find a slight advantage to
work with here but now they both work
drunk Oh Sarah justice real boys all
three of them Shazaam twisted Shawn all
go down to it and it's a four tail
around for Cole the ball won't go down
at the sea T's boosting up they trying
to deny everything they can codes Aaron
strikes
I'll find the head choke straight away
the full-back is stopped as he takes
down as we will see here with cold at
this point nice holding back now good
trigger discipline I just spotted the
fourth player in the meantime though
Davie finds that first kill Saco does
respond with his own pickup an alcohol
strikes just tapping so casually and
their three kills just like that stomach
freak and Jason are all go down at the
city then you thought you can float one
more play it back to what Stacey and
calls ear off all my goodness you can't
just individually pay you guys what I
eat Dylan it's pretty insane to think
that he is the secondary or foot but
manages to clean up tough meet with this
freak a
even more stacked against SK balls
plunge to the B box thigh here goes era
a phenomenal talent gonna be up to the
task because they line up through many
go to the double spray now Morton's are
not getting the avenging Frankie this is
quickly turned into SK gaming's round
the bottom also under control k ng
finished off just trying to retreat back
into the site does a lot of damage there
and pulse you're arrested with the mp9
that feels true let's get caught find me
but still shouldn't be a big problem
here for the rest of this K to follow up
on it in the fact for the smoke finish
coals here as they need to see the
people he's shooting at 3rd kill coming
in they're taking down maze quad kill
for cold Serie three men down IV is it
gonna be enough to break it open one
good kill here could absolutely crack
open this a bomb sign especially when
there's only three people on it's gonna
wrap around the corner cold Joe's got
him that's the bomb he's gonna call it
over Big Chill he gets another one and
the triple the best player in the world
shows up again
every comes in darkness doubts from that
range and an FBI
an easy headshot allowed to pick up the
ball he can actually rush this tool
repeated there's no but they're -
they're nice and another plant a minute
for SK picked up at Emma for to work
with fashion hold on a tight position
manages to crawl on the damn hole and
make his way to little feet replant them
as mentions maybe and that's to hold off
these that know a treat you to the stamp
this happen for can absolutely win this
round at this point aim punch is the
biggest factory on the old patch it
might as well and still a significant
factor
and prevail for twist to the end he's
actually gonna have that third before he
falls huge play from Lucas mainly type
something in chat bolt who Weinstock
will leave it all on cold one before
Lucas locks it down and cold up at all
minutes seven on the clock I know
exactly where he is
do it back to this you as payin look at
this that's for four cool all headshots
and now it's the 1v1 against Zack you
know some say the mark of a true great
is a high level of performance when it
matters the most and over the years
coldzera has shown us that he truly has
ice in his veins whether it's an online
league or a major grand final on land
cold doesn't choke cold Syrah that
doesn't happen very often he's isolated
back here still getting a kill but
they're just penetrating this chicken
hut very quickly simple gets one fall
and they tried to knife him but changed
his mind
halfway through coach Eric Whitehill
tonight sir what's happening simple
oh no that's a huge giveaway cold sir
with the quad kill instead does it work
out this time again mo is there to find
falling but coldzera on the double is
doing the job he does best
market don't you finds it in the ends
with zero he could be the one who
clutches it out he's already on to four
tracks only cease to fight he doesn't
pull through cold zero goes off and
takes a height advantage does he clutch
it up it does no it does it does it's
fifteen fourteen zero single-handedly
aces it out there comes cold
there's a lot around he's still always
there you guys cold is pretty cheeky
uses perfect is this hold is insane
I've only cast in one other game but oh
you know knife that no no wear it oh my
god I love it sometimes don't forget
that close to Wednesday's lemon out of
Hank dude the stat still stands
look at the balls on him to hold that
angle though like that sovaldi 3hb way
to play nice in his DNA
The Iceman Cometh
[Applause]
line up that trick a clue live across
the hat it's all Thomas can't get there
for taco he's got cold walking in that's
cool
face
courtesy of Niko have the advantage on
true go down here you've called Sara
doesn't deny it but he should be able to
and again and again we're just going
backwards and forwards and now it's into
a 1v1 Guardian hasn't had an impact on
this round could certainly have a big
one that's called Sara now in that 1v1
will find the angle and whoop didn't
quite get the perfect spray down but
it's good enough on the toilet zero next
year's highest rated player over 2060
and he started it off he's gotta get the
head show of a second
[Applause]
he views us the planet clay rise that
let's get out and shot zero we'll pull
it back it's all the tech 9 in hand no
armored door with no be punishing Volans
got the shot on body palms gonna go down
it's a 2 versus 3 the most time they
can't find cold he's playing this out
correctly spots up Smith spots up the
second as well I'm not sure why my mic
is going absolutely insane
Oh letting over cool he might do it
alone
oh is it reliable it is cool 0 makes it
a cold day in hell for g2 time is
ticking though he's running out of time
with which to do that time staying in
the long position say that when he's got
to get on this bond are you selling a
truckload 0 he's on the bomb now holding
it two seconds
quiet girl ridiculous plush and he's
like come on back
now Derek help
very
[Music]
Oh enough this one's down Tuesday's
gonna get a bit interesting
[Music]
one on three in this situation trapped
in the corner it's very unlikely you get
out of this but they're not checking me
just yet he's gonna come around the
corner picks up one taco town gold goes
for the friend he gets another one a kid
he get the thought 1 in 12 bullets left
caging on the other side three picks up
every single kill chased away boys
[Music]
they have helped it against me so they
have to lose weight and looking for the
headshot it's fallen he's not gonna find
it
find someone play with the mice is there
two trades and now it's all on cold with
the baby bears the one and the pressure
is on device with only three nice
witness fight with my crap but I think
once again I think once again there will
not be enough time for the diffuse
SK gaming
[Music]
[Applause]
well guys that was the best of coldzera
now I almost didn't bring this up but
from my money hold his vivre SCS player
in the world
he's got the consistency he's got the
highlight reel and he's got the
championship rings so to speak to back
it all up now if you're in the comment
section talking about Nikko or simple or
even my boy Guardian I respect it but
don't add me thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]